[ Indistinct shouting ]
-Hey, guys. What's up?
How you doing?
-Shh. Come on, bro.
-Hold on, hold on, Jimmy.
-You guys watching
March Madness?
-March Madn--
Bro, this is "Bridgerton."
The hottest thing out right now.
-This is hot.
This is high-level wagering.
-I didn't know that you could
wager on "Bridgerton."
-My man.
-"I didn't know you could wager
on Bridgerton."
Come on, bro.
-Bro.
-Let him know
what you were gambling.
-Finna, I got $500
on Anthony kissing
the hand of Kate
by the end of season 4.
$500, bro.
-Amateur, amateur.
-That's a lot.
3-1 odds Eloise slaps
someone with a white glove.
About to go down, let's go.
Let's watch right now.
-It's a bad beat.
[Glove slaps]
-Pay me up!
-Ahhh, man
Give me my money,
give me my money.
-I'll -- I'll see you guys
on the stage.
-We'll see you on stage.
-Yo, Jimmy, uh, Jimmy,
um, I'mma need -- can you --
do you --
what's your PayPal?
-Wow, wow, wow.
-Yo. Yo, Jim--
-Yo, yo, give me that chain.